et on commence avec de la musique et
plus particulièrement de rap électro
mais également d'écologie les trois
réunis ça donne le wear festival ça
aurait lieu samedi prochain et cette
organisé par deux associations de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye anywise et la clé
pour en parler avec nous Mathieu Poiré
bonsoir alors vous êtes le président de
l'association anywilde anywhilde comment
ça se trouve anywise alors première
question Mathieu Poiret alors c'est quoi
l'électorat parce que les deux ça se
conjugue bien
alors déjà sur la création de ce
festival c'est vrai qu'on a tout de
suite parti sur ces deux styles de
musique
aujourd'hui
dans dans le rap on retrouve beaucoup de
touches électro et puis même inversement
donc c'est pour ça que voilà on a on a
choisi aussi nos artistes pour
construire notre notre lin-up autour de
ces deux styles et puis c'est aussi de
styles qui sont très très écoutés auprès
des jeunes et donc comme notre festival
est quand même à destination
majoritairement des jeunes c'est
important pour nous de retrouver ces
deux styles de musique
majoritairement des jeunes on imagine
avec l'Europe mais est-ce que ça attire
aussi des personnes un peu plus
âgées finalement que vous attendiez pas
alors on n'est pas fermé à avoir plus
que des jeunes bien sûr ça tout le monde
peut venir tout le monde est bienvenu
nous l'objectif surtout c'était
d'attirer des jeunes c'était surtout
pour leur parler en fait écologie leur
parler développement durable parce que
du coup l'association anywise c'est une
cible qu'on touche beaucoup avec qui on
a envie de parler moi pour ma part j'ai
18 ans donc c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus simple de parler aussi
avec des jeunes de certaines thématiques
et de passer à l'action le principe de
ce festival du coup c'était vraiment
voilà de se dire je viens un festival
engagé je viens pour m'amuser parce que
je suis jeune et j'ai envie de m'éclater
c'est ça tout à fait alors justement
votre association anywald elle défend la
cause environnementale ou peut-être vous
pouvez peut-être nous parler de cette
association quelles sont les causes que
que sont les actions que vous mettez en
place concrètement quelle est la
démarche
c'est une association que j'ai fondé il
y a 5 ans maintenant on était au départ
de 6 potes on va dire à se dire on a
envie de faire une action on a envie de
faire quelque chose à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour agir et donc
tout de suite on a créé donc une
association
et on a été accompagné d'ailleurs par la
ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye mais
aussi la clé qui nous accompagne au-delà
du festival sur l'association depuis un
petit moment maintenant c'est
l'association du coup autour du
développement durable l'idée c'est
d'aller voir les jeunes on part du
principe que maintenant on est à peu
près tous au courant que on est dans une
situation complexe donc là l'idée c'est
surtout de se dire voilà comment on
passe à l'action de nos thématiques du
coup alors c'est évidemment on va dire
du ce qu'on appelle nous du basique
opération de nettoyage de
sensibilisation etc etc mais on a une
thématique aussi qui nous tient
particulièrement à coeur et qu'on
aimerait beaucoup plus développer c'est
les comptes que c'était cette peur
vis-à-vis des problèmes environnementaux
et sociaux donc voilà et puis on a lancé
aussi très récemment une friperie
solidaire par exemple l'idée voilà c'est
d'apporter des vêtements que nous on
revend à très très faible coût pour
financer les projets de l'association et
en même temps ça permet à tout le monde
de pouvoir
s'habiller avec ses moyens on va dire et
donc ce samedi aux organisez aussi un
festival dans cette même lignée comment
est-ce que ça s'est fait comment est-ce
que vous êtes dit bon ben on va créer un
festival qui va mêler la musique et puis
l'écologie
c'est une histoire qui est un peu assez
marrante il y a 3 ans on s'est dit on a
vraiment envie d'organiser un événement
pour pour des jeunes justement mais pour
parler environnement on sait très vite
aperçu que ça allait être compliqué
d'attirer les jeunes si on fait juste
des conférences et juste des ateliers
donc on s'est dit on s'est dit on va
rajouter le côté musique et en plus bah
nous personnellement l'équipe on allait
beaucoup en festival aussi donc c'est
aussi une ambiance qu'on avait envie de
retrouver à Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc
du coup voilà on s'est dit voilà il faut
mélanger les villages et en même temps
la partie musique on s'est rapproché de
la clé qui tout de suite à sauter dedans
parce que c'est un projet qui est super
cool et en même temps qui est super
fédérateur donc au départ on avait voilà
nos deux structures et en fait petit à
petit on a été rejoint par plein
d'autres structures à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est un festival
qui se veut très très local sur les
partenaires villages mais aussi sur sur
certains des artistes on a aussi qu'on a
aussi choisi donc du coup voilà donc ça
fait trois ans qu'on travaille dessus il
y a eu des échecs évidemment ça fait
partie du jeu et nous aussi le but c'est
d'apprendre d'apprendre le métier de
producteur d'apprendre le métier de
programmateur etc etc donc du coup voilà
là on a on va dire la meilleure version
de ce qu'on de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
sur we are festival vous parlez d'un
festival et d'écologie ça me fait penser
au festival we love green qui a été
critiqué l'année dernière par rapport à
l'impact écologique pendant le festival
notamment les nuisances sonores par
rapport aux animaux c'est des choses que
vous avez pris en compte aussi pour
votre festival oui alors Willow green
qu'au départ on a fait une grosse veille
documentaire autour de ce festival pour
savoir comment il s'est construit
comment aujourd'hui il a envie de se
développer nous on est parti du principe
qu'on s'établissait d'abord une espèce
de charte éco-responsable à respecter au
maximum pour pouvoir voilà construire le
festival et par exemple on a aucune
musique à l'extérieur donc voilà le parc
de la clé mise à part un petit fond
sonore au niveau de la restauration tout
ce qu'on aura même nos conférences ne
seront pas sonorisées donc voilà
biodiversité
mais après voilà cette charte elle va
aussi sur la restauration par exemple
vous parlez de brull of green c'est vrai
que aussi sont pas mal investi là-dessus
nous aussi on essaye de faire au maximum
mais cette charte elle va aussi
s'établir sur sur les transports sur la
santé voilà plein de choses comme ça
alors on va parler un petit peu de la
programmation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un peu des des artistes qui
seront présents alors les artistes qu'on
a qu'on a choisi on a d'abord du local
du très très local on commence par
exemple avec Venise qui vient de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui est un jeune
DJ de 19 ans voilà donc ça c'est sa
première scène en festival après on a la
117 parties qui est un donc un groupe de
trois jeunes rappeurs pareil donc
Saint-Germain-en-Laye trap et puis Paris
si j'ai du mal de bêtises donc voilà
l'idée c'est donc trois styles de rap
aussi bien à eux et voilà ils vont jouer
tous ensemble pendant une heure et après
du coup on arrive sur nos trois têtes
d'affiches qui n'ont pas été choisies au
hasard puisque ces trois têtes
d'affiches par exemple donc on a deux DJ
azdek et bastique et un rappeur STO mais
STO a déjà collaboré avec asdec par
exemple Bastille que joue aussi des
mélodies qui sont électro mais qui sont
aussi rap donc voilà finalement ils
savent jouer les deux et c'est pour ça
que on a aussi un lien et une harmonie
entre les deux styles de musique toute
la soirée qui a déjà fait d'ailleurs
Lola palosa et puis l'électrique Park
qui a été Chatou dans les eaux Vladimir
cauchemar notamment qui était électrique
Park en septembre dernier
donc voilà quand même et puis c'est toi
qui commence à bien se faire entendre
alors lui il vient de Lille mais quand
même comment savoir une bonne communauté
aussi donc c'est important de te ramener
ce genre d'artiste à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye voilà les ramener
dans des endroits où vous pourrez pas
habituellement les voir et du coup
globalement ce sont des artistes engagés
pour la cause environnementale
c'est une très bonne question
pour cette première édition on n'a pas
pu malheureusement bien bien creusé
certains points même si il a fallu faire
des choix que ce soit niveau logistique
mais même budget donc voilà maintenant
sur est-ce que les artistes sont engagés
j'espère que personnellement ils sont
engagés maintenant voilà on n'a pas non
plus pris un artiste qui a fait des
photos sur Instagram très limites ou ce
genre de choses quoi on essaie de faire
aussi attention à ça
il s'agit d'une première édition vous
attendez à peu près combien de personnes
alors on est à ça d'être complet et les
informations ce matin donc on est sur
une salle de 220 places voilà il doit
rester peut-être une petite quarantaine
de places voilà sur les trois jours qui
restent à devrait vite partir et bien
merci beaucoup Mathieu d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc si vous êtes
intéressé il reste encore quelques
places le we are festival se tiendra ce
samedi 15 avril à la clé à Saint-Germain
les débuts des festivités 14 heures et
début des concerts 18 heures